[Music]  in October 1989 43 women around the  world gave birth none of these women had  been pregnant when the day first began  how much do you want for it  I have adopted six children  gifted with abilities far beyond the  ordinary  I give you the Umbrella Academy does  anyone wish to speak it was a monster  everything about our family's insane  always had  [Music]  is that my skirt oh yeah this it's very  breathing on the bits mrs. C nothing's  changed  I jumped forward and got stuck in the  future you know what I found  absolutely nothing what's it supposed to  happen in eight days there was someone  out there who's trying to stop me from  preventing the apocalypse we need the  full force of the academy bingo  gay sisters yay sisters  get up we're going we're save the world  Oh  you  [Music]